did prince charming not learn anything
from roughstock again he's married for
the love and not advantage it works out
a bit better for the prince and I think
he I think he learned not to go into
Westeros I know that you tone down your
Scottish accent and I was wondering if
that was a requirement for the role
first of all and second of all was there
anything you could take from your role
as Robb Stark to use in Cinderella such
as maybe horse riding or anything
um well the accent I had to obviously
tighter to Derek and I don't know if I'd
been Scottish it would have been a bit
of a statement or for the Kingdom Wars I
think so and it was it was much better
to do that and and it worked a lot
better I think and in terms of Robb
Stark I mean yeah this horse trading and
sword fighting and stuff like that but I
suppose when the parallels with plans
kit is this sense of responsibility
being thrust on you you've not asked for
and I think that's something I kind of I
could relate to the two of them I think
it's a really strange unique position to
be in as is royalty where where you have
no choice over over what your duties are
you